john i want you to do the next topic
because john found this and it's
basically the math on how bitcoin could
reach one million dollars a coin john
what you got for us here cool so james
lavish had an excellent threat about how
bitcoin can actually reach a million
dollars a coin he said btc will
eventually be worth a million dollars
for per coin he's obviously very bullish
on this right so he said it's just pure
math and had an excellent threat on it
he said there are currently around 700
trillion of global investment assets in
the world 137 trillion in bonds
117 trillion in stocks real estate 290
trillion um arts and collectibles 22
trillion gold only 10 trillion and m2
cash savings etc at 130 trillion that's
176 trillion in total so at 42 per coin
btc's market value is around 900 billion
dollars give or take 100 billion that is
only 0.13 percent of global assets so
what he's describing here is basically
when you get an inflow from other assets
of cash into bitcoin it's gonna it has
to draw money from somewhere right they
do print money but they're not gonna
print it that fast for bitcoin to raise
that appreciate that much um so if one
percent of the total assets flew into
bitcoin that would put it at a 7
trillion dollar market and 337 000
per coin that's a lot of coin 2
14 trillion 667
000 per bitcoin and
three percent of total net asset inflows
would increase the market cap to 21
trillion and put it at one million
dollars a coin so they really just need
three percent of all total assets to go
into it um it sounds pretty simple when
you put it at three percent but that's a
lot of freaking money being poured into
bitcoin so we have to see if that
actually happens over time but i think
as adoption increases i think more
people more money will flow into the
bitcoin space joe do you think that this
is realistic three percent of global
a million assets
a bitcoin price yeah yeah yeah yeah
i think that there's no doubt that this
happens it's just a question of is this
in the uh relatively short term or does
this happen over 25 30 years right but
yeah uh three percent of the world's
assets flowing into
an asset that can't be debased an asset
that nobody controls that literally you
can hold and you have millions of people
plugging computers in the world
defending your purchasing power these
could get through i mean 137 trillion
bonds what are you guys doing to put
your money in bonds well yeah i i think
it's gonna go a lot more than three
percent but yeah but here's the other
piece that i'll say is i think that it
it'll get to a million dollars a million
dollars per coin without actually
hitting the three percent because what
you're going to see is total assets
globally it's going to continue to grow
and so an easy example would be i'm not
saying it's going to happen but this
would be like the the math if we doubled
the total global assets right then it
would only be one and a half percent of
global assets and you get a million
dollars a coin so i think that it's
somewhere in between there right it
probably doesn't have to get to three
percent because we're going to continue
to see the expansion i mean you know the
fed's balance sheet is 10x basically in
12 years so you're going to continue to
see assets growing and growing and
growing uh and bitcoin will just kind of
continue to eat into some of these other
asset classes right i think that there's
uh everyone a lot of people point to the
stock to flow model right and it's based
on havings and you can see kind of uh
the supply and demand equation work out
and
you know they they think after uh
after the next two halvings then we'll
hit a million dollars a coin right and
my whole thing is like i think it's
gonna happen uh
probably a little quicker than most
people expect because when you start to
think about like the spread of
information and how quickly these things
take off like the internet has totally
knocked down the barriers to all this
stuff right it's all an education thing
if you go to someone in one of these
countries that can use a technology like
bitcoin like turkey for example or
venezuela or
any of these other kind of countries
where they're currently seeing their
money debased they're seeing record high
inflation rates uh and they can't
protect their purchasing power if you
explain to them what bitcoin is how it
can be helpful how they can use it for
purchases how they can store their money
and protect their purchasing power how
like you said people are defending their
purchasing power all around the world
and no one can control it the monetary
policy is no literally all these people
their entire life they've dealt with
monetary policy that they have no idea
what's going to happen right they just
have no idea no control over their money
and this puts the power back in their
hands and the other thing too is
protection right like a lot of these
people live in governments or under
governments where their money can just
be taken their money can be stolen and
seized and with bitcoin that's not going
to happen and i think once you explain
kind of the use case of a lot of these
things the people that it that it
impacts them like literally i think it's
difficult for people to understand in
the united states because uh we sit here
in a country where we're we're very
comfortable you know what i mean like we
we have inflation everyone's complaining
about seven percent and it's not uh it's
not a good thing by any means but
ultimately uh it is a very small concern
relative to what other people are
dealing with when it comes to being
underbanked record high inflation their
assets are being seized they can't
protect their purchasing power all of
these things and and the use case has
never been stronger for people in those
countries so i think once you start to
democracize the education process of it
and more people understand what's
happening i think we're drastically
going to see an adoption curve and this
stuff is going to pick up much quicker
than i think most people expect go off
king you agree or not
yeah of course
i think the funniest part about
everything you just said is that there's
a bunch of economists and central
bankers around the world that built
their entire careers but their entire
life thinking about monetary policy and
now there's a bunch of people just like
yeah so like that human-based uh
monetary policy stuff like we're out on
that one like we're just gonna go over
here to this machine like this machine's
better at it than you guys are yeah and
i think that there's a lot of people
like what do you mean the machine you're
like no like literally like we don't
even we don't this whole industry like
we're just done with you guys like we
don't need you anymore
i i think it is absolutely comical when
you start to think that people are
intently listening to a
federal reserve meeting to hear if he
says the words hawkish dovish how his
tone is when you can literally just rely
on software and a computer and it is not
going to change people are protecting it
no one can mess with it any of this
stuff and i think when you start to
think about in that context like it's a
no-brainer the other piece that uh i
think people shy away from saying but we
should just say it is that bitcoin's an
automated central bank and i think most
people wrap their heads around
automation and they're like yeah of
course automation's gonna happen like
we're gonna have self-driving cars at
some point in the future i don't know if
that happens in one year or 20 years but
at some point we're gonna have
self-driving cars right we also see a
ton of automation and uh kind of in the
manufacturing space from the supply
chain space we see automation happening
everywhere it's a deflationary force on
society
but nobody wants to just say like look
we already have automated central bank
the central bank literally is software
code it executes based on transparent
software that's open source that
literally anyone can audit at any time
and it's verifiable by a billion plus
people around the world at every single
moment and ultimately people are going
to trust and believe something that not
only is transparent that's auditable but
also that is known in advance and
therefore it is more predictable and so
ultimately what we are watching is we
are watching the adoption of an
automated central bank automations come
in every part of your life and yes it is
coming to your money as well and once
people started to think about it as it's
simply an automated central bank it's
like yo you ever seen the memes where
it's like choose your fighter yeah right
and it's like take central bankers from
around the world and then just software
choose your fighter
like i know who i'm picking